suis désolé tu trouves ton équilibre ou
trois mois avec votre amitié et votre
amour ah ouais tu dois être ici
brigitte manabe sa voiture a encore
reparlé des cinq cent mille euros que tu
m'as demandé non juifs et de sa
dimension ses morts ses morts je serai
je serai enfin 2 en fin de vie
financière dans quinze jours c'est pas
leurs quinze jours mais n'ont alors oui
mais voilà quand
les pieds
ça veut dire le 21 septembre pour
l'automne voilà pour l'automne elle sera
sans procès elles sont de paiement n'en
sais rien non franchement qu'est ce qui
va se passer bah je savais que c'est
l'argent c'est anton pas 1,9 donc quand
y'a plus là n'a plus alors qu
il a le don de casser l'ombre non mais
c'est pas la passe et qu'est ce qui se
passe dans quinze jours
battant 15 jours j'ai des chances que je
ne pourrai pas honorer parce que j'avais
un ami qui m'est proposé une caution
qu'il nomme et qui ne m'a pas normal pas
pourquoi n'es tu m'as tu me dit
est ce qu'une personne 3 ici le cheval
est ce que je peux toi est-ce que je
peux traiter nos âmes non non c'est sûr
tu m'a proposé et je suis parti en
vacances ça et j'ai oublié et c'est vrai
après oui j'ai eu le temps de réfléchir
maintenant
maman qui vous dit qu'il a une échéance
nous mettre extrêmement compétent mais
ce qui va se passer pour toi je n'en
sais rien je verrai je vais gérer au cou
au jour le jour donc c'est à dire c'est
quoi comme jeu gg je vais faire l'an
passé nous mettant en place une solution
que je n'ai pas donc je ne sais pas ce
que je vais faire mais tu vas garder un
toit ah oui bien sûr nos maris
savent attendus dire non et est en train
d'avoir ces mots ne sont jamais battus
donc alors donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer car il va se passer mais ça va
être plus compliqué c'est à dire mais
c'est compliqué je vous dise quoi à
l'hôtel adlon millions et nous fait
chier
[Applaudissements]
et
agen
avec ses 6
chez vous
[Musique]
en avez vous moi j'en ai pas les moyens
mais un effort a fait en king
[Applaudissements]
s'est révélé ce que tu me prêter de
l'argent et tout de suite
suite et besoin de sentir des gens aient
eu raymond je lui prête tout de suite
été bien de tuer moi moi parce que moi
non
mais nalinnes tout de suite tout de
suite parce que marc est différent sinon
je suis prêt nous fait quand même très
dur avec benjamin parce que cette année
il est quand même parti au casino il
vous en prêter de l'argent et alors les
arrondis dit mais qu'est-ce que je m'en
fous et une journée mabhouh les rangs
mais qu'est ce que j'ai mais il ne
rendra jamais
il est comme ça
tu as beau bébé oui tu la mets quand
j'ai appris ma défense je te prête
l'argent et moi que tu sembles ça va tu
sais rien mais alors castaldi je te le
dynamisme le problème si je suis a
mauvaise presse et précis la
réputation te prêter - gestion des
prisons parce que tu attaques cérébrales
6 sous le par l'union toi j'ai adoré
tourner pognon que cyril te donne chaque
mois azul pour les landes et dans les
dom dans la chaîne logistique
ah oui mais
voilà la boisson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il pourrait déjà face nous a pas dans la
boisson
service dans le jeu aussi je croirais
tout je prends la dette de la drogue
à suez nord-est il importerait noël à
droite si on perd on rigole c'est de la
drogue non non oui mais bon ni l'alcool
ni droite pour l'instant concentre toi
sur des problèmes alors oui je rappelle
que l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
à la cigarette or s'il est touché de la
mer en jeu regardez moi et je le dis je
n'ai pas peur de le dire je ne bois pas
je ne fume pas je ne me drogue pas mais
bon je suis content quand même
oui non non je faisais
mais c'est vrai que moi a été bon non
bah oui bah j'ai besoin de leur dire
vous êtes riche et en bonne santé
mais là tu as vu là il asséné la mula
les deux là étaient légaux nous savons
qui me ramenait bien avant ça j'en ai
fait le ménage dans cette émission vous
remercie de ramallah il me la retire
toi par toi
[Applaudissements]
véridique le bar est bien ouvert en face
l'armée c'est vrai et ce qui ne tue pas
me rend plus fort
a dit que tu dis ça
mais vous avez été quand la barre héros
là mais sans écrire ou européenne est-ce
que tu commences à fait mort d'un shérif
mais t'as rien faire et puis le som judo
2 qu'est ce que tu as fait je n'ai pas
demandé de l'argent
mais l'émotion
[Musique]
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
m